dans la cour de ce transporteur le
va-et-vient est continue depuis que psa
est passé en production vsd les camions
de cette entreprise ont tout juste le
temps de faire le plein et malgré dix
embauches ces derniers mois les 90
conducteurs titulaires ne suffisent plus
en effet on peut plus répondre à nos
clients on a plus de personnel roulant
pour répondre à cette demande et c'est
une problématique parce qu'aujourd'hui
il ya des parts de marché qui vont
commencer à partir à s'évaporer un peu
ch et où d'autres concurrents et
malheureusement on peut pas y pallier il
y à bien la solution de l'intérim mais
le transporteur n'a pu trouver que 35
recrues quand il en faudrait dix de plus
la trop bonne santé économique de l'airé
urbaine a son revers
c'est effectivement de plus en plus
compliqué de trouver de bons profils
aujourd'hui car le bassin commence à
être très essorée nous avons par exemple
aujourd'hui déployé une opération chez
psa où nous faisons venir des
réunionnais
on va le faire pour la deuxième année
consécutive avec tout un plan
d'accompagnement
deux possibilités soit 7 financé on va
dire les permis de faire évoluer les
permis nos candidats ou de passer par
part de la formation
donc là la région elle présente il y a
quelques mois la fédération des
transports routiers lancé son opération
tremplin afin de recenser les besoins
dans une filière que la pyramide des
âges fait fondre à vitesse grand v
mais le plus compliqué reste à susciter
les vocations trop peu nombreuses malgré
les débouchés c'est un métier qui a été
dévalorisée très longtemps on a vu une
image du conducteur routier négative
c'était le conducteur avec des gros bras
qui était dans le cambouis aujourd'hui
ça a changé mais ça ne se sait pas donc
l'image est vraiment à revaloriser on
n'en menait pas ses enfants dans des
formations et pourtant dans des lycées
professionnels aujourd'hui on en a un
regret lycée fairte qui est très bon qui
il donne vraiment des perspectives
d'emploi emploie 96 % cdi normalement il
manque aujourd'hui près d'un demi
millier de conducteurs poids lourds en
bourgogne franche comté
un déficit que le rythme des formations
ne comblera pas immédiatement de quoi
freiner les ardeurs d'un secteur qui
revit après des années de crise aiguë